this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app everybody
switch into the cash app so let's all
get on board it's the number one finance
app in the App Store and they've
introduced the cash card a new black
debit card that you can design yourself
via the app allowing you to use the cash
that you keep in the app anywhere you
want plus it's the best way to pay
people back I use it all the time
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now this episode is also brought
to you by blue apron the leading meal
kit delivery service in the US and while
many people know what we do many don't
know about the types of meals you eat
when you cook with blue apron you're not
just having burgers for dinner you're
making short rib burgers with a hoppy
cheddar sauce on a pretzel bun
I've been eating blue apron now for a
few months and it's really good and you
don't feel bad afterwards which a lot of
the food in America makes you feel that
way so but this is great blue apron is
treating my listeners to their first
three meals a $30 value with your first
order if you visit blue apron com /
Congrats so check out this menu and get
your $30 off with free shipping at blue
apron com / Congrats
blue apron a better way to cook
[Music]
switch it up in there like merry new
year or like happy Christmas yeah it's
2018 I it's Miley I think it's my least
favorite holiday is New Year
I don't like it just makes me anxious
man it makes me anxious because nothing
is different but everyone acts like it's
gonna be different and so it just like
makes me anxious that secretly
everything is gonna be different even
though it's not even though I know it's
not but everyone's gonna be saying it
and making me feel like maybe it is and
then same goes down new year same
you same old you and the worst part
about it is going back to the gym you go
to the gym and for like two weeks is
like everybody is all using everything
and then the lazy fat pieces of
fall by the wayside and then by
February you're good to go you're good
to go again it's the year of the dog
that jizz that Chinese doesn't matter
what's the year of the dog doesn't
matter it's a year of the dog or it's
just another year yes it's just another
year was I mean what's the what's that
mean if it's the year of the dog
nothing cool everything's gonna be the
same great a Chinese zodiac dog
prediction people born in 1922 1934 1946
19 doesn't matter 19 doesn't matter 19
nothin 2,000 it doesn't matter and 2018
are members of the dog Chinese zodiac
sign dogs together could fight for bones
what the does that mean
could you know giving us the option hey
it's nothing dude how about those
Chinese did Chinese New Year I was
always a different it's always different
and it's like can't but you're like all
of a sudden like people are all excited
but it's August or something and
they're like hey it's the Chinese New
Year or May or whatever the it is
and then like white people try to
pretend like they give a and then
you see that big-ass thing going
down the parade with the big head and
tassels on the body and you try to act
like it's not the scariest thing a
six-year-old could see hey it's the year
of the dog get the big-ass thing
with the mask on and have 10 Chinese
people fit inside it and walk down the
street hey what are we doing you know
just go to work
February 16th is the Chinese New Year I
guess and it's the year of the dog
so doesn't mean you know what the
interesting thing about that is it
doesn't mean anything I want news to be
like so it's a Chinese New Year here
it's on February whenever and it just
turned 2018 in China well it didn't say
year of the dog and the interesting
thing about that is it doesn't matter
back to you yeah so I went and I did
shows in San Diego I'm gonna say
something here I'm gonna say something
here and I want you to know I mean it
and it's gonna turn some people off and
I want you to know I don't give a
because I'm serious and it's how I feel
and since it's how I feel I don't feel
bad about it San Diego sucks
period there you go there you have it
there you have it I've been there a
bunch I tried to act like it was nice
and good and fun and it blows
donkey dicks it sucks
San Diego sucks I went and I did
four shows there at the House of Blues I
did shows there last year at the
observatory I've done shows there all
the time and it is Amateur Night every
time man every time people Hooton holler
and yell out and say
there's a girl that screamed out take
your shirt off I threw her the out
and then there were other girls that
wouldn't stop talking and then dudes on
the upper level that wouldn't stop
talking and every time I go to San Diego
that's the kind of crowd I get and it
sucks and it sucks too because
there are great people that live
in San Diego dude I met people after the
show and they were like thank you so
much
sorry about those hecklers and that
sucks for those people I was in the
Gaslamp District or whatever the
go yourself man everyone's drunk
all over the place
I saw people getting kicked out of
diners by security I saw you know just I
saw a guy get thrown out he was like I'm
not going anywhere and then the security
took him and pinned him down and there
was another guy with a ripped shirt for
no reason he just had a ripped shirt in
the diner I have it on my Instagram and
he was just had a ripped shirt for no
reason sitting down having Brett dinner
at like 2:00 a.m. and the other guy got
kicked out and they pinned him down in
the guy was screaming now you're
breaking my arm you're breaking my arm
and it was so blood-curdling and it made
me realize one thing that I could never
be in war I could never be in war the
way this guy was yelling at three
security guards that was pinning his arm
made me think like you see in war you
see people dying and getting their like
head cut off and screaming I couldn't
take this kid screaming you breaking my
arm it was very unsettling and
his girl was like you're breaking his
arm and she couldn't do anything about
it and then I was like why did you
rough the guy up Nate and then
then the and the the manager was like
well we called my server a so they
attacked him like it was like nothing at
it was like I'm not going anywhere and
then they just grabbed him and
pinned him down and ripped his leg and
arm apart and then was like yeah I was
like what happened oh he called the
server a name like what dude San Diego
sucks if I lived there I would
kill myself how about that it's
it's sucks dude and everyone acts like
it's beautiful and it is the weather's
great but like the look the standing the
surrounding areas of San Diego probably
they're beautiful dude
they're great and people dude I've done
shows in La Jolla everyone talks about
how great La Jolla is dude crowds in La
Jolla suck
it's amateur night dude they all come
out and they're like they think that oh
you're here to entertain me you're here
you're so you know dude
audiences that act like you're lucky to
be there I picked it because of you
performers pick there because
you go there because you can go
anywhere it doesn't matter I'll go to
San Diego or I'll go to Denver or it'll
go to Jacksonville it doesn't
matter
oh yeah dude perform for us no dude dude
I came you bought the ticket sit down
laughing don't laugh that's it if you
scream take the shirt off I'll throw you
out dude I was like this girl screamed
out she take your shirt off and I was
like I shut the up dude and she was
like what this and that I was like yo
you gotta go and I threw her out and and
she was like what's got what and then
she i barely checked my snapchats like
people can send me them and every now
and then i'll check one or two or
sometimes I hit it by mistake
cuz I'm just looking through it and like
this girl
snapchat came up and it was like we just
got kicked out of the Chris D'Elia show
and we're still over here wondering why
all we were doing was laughing and
anyway you Chris D'Elia
but we still love you were you partying
afterwards that's that right there is
San Diego that right there is San Diego
this chick screaming out take
your shirt off and I throw her out and
she legitimately doesn't get it
afterwards and then thinks I'm gonna
hang out with her what hey you
know what hey girl this is Earth this is
Earth I don't know what the you're
used to but if you ruin the show not
gonna be round yeah I I literally threw
you out of the place I'm at why the
do you think I want to come back to the
place where you are
happy New Year dude you know
dude people all oh no we're so sorry
dude they were ruining my openers show
these are their this chick and these
four dudes ruining their show out there
whoo yeah yeah screaming and the
dudes were talking all loud like
privileged pieces of you know just
with watches on hanging over the balcony
and they were just being so rude and
then I said to the manager I was like yo
you guys got to watch these guys man cuz
like whatever and they were watch it
kept talking my openers everyone I had
three openers everyone was like
yo you guys gotta be quiet and then I
was like man just go talk to him
before I go on and let him know that I'm
gonna throw him out if they keep doing
it dude I give him six warnings
and then I went out and then as I was
going onstage they were being escorted
out already because the bouncers were
like all right you guys are just
done I didn't even like tell him to
throw him out and but it's like you
can't act like a person dude actually
the person dude I can't believe what San
Diego was like it was like hell on earth
it's like hell on earth the
paddy wagon pulled up and there were
like so many drunk people in there just
like bashing it it was like a
wildebeest was in there just trying to
it was like somebody was growing
into the Hulk it literally was like boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom and
then it opened up in the cop the cops
pulled over opened up and this no
this lady I sky here in the
paddy wagon I hear she has lopez
she has lopez and the cops are all right
come out and they unlock the inside
there's an inner inner gate in the van
there's the van and then in those doors
there's another cage and then you open
up the cage like there's Oh like
there's like the World of
Warcraft beasts in it with the fangs
that go up over the
that by the way when they have the I
don't like how when they make trolls or
beasts in movies they have their
their fangs that go up over and they
talk and they ugh the it's like
we get it dude they're beasts
that wouldn't be that because it would
scrape the it would scrape under
their noses
and I don't like that but she chews like
she has lupus she has lupus and they're
like ok come out and they bring out the
girl who apparently has lupus and
straight up
she's got no clothes on dude she just
has jeans on and her titties are out in
San Diego her titties are out and she's
like this doing the cover where she's
got the hand over one tit and the almost
elbow over the other tit and she was
like and she comes out and I swear to
god this is what she's saying I have
white parents I have white parents y'all
was actually really sad now that I think
about it man I watched so much
go and look I get it I don't
live in war time well I mean I
guess we'd all do but I don't live in
like where they're fighting I know that
the world is there's a lot worse places
in the world and I get my sheltered
little piece of
brain saw the San Diego thing and I was
like oh my god but I just now I
feel bad now I feel bad about what I'm
saying but hey whatever man it was just
like get me the out of San Diego
and then and then and how about this
everyone in San Diego was like hey
can have fun in Riverside that place
sucks
everyone was like have fun in Riverside
that place sucks dude I went to
Riverside and did New Year's Eve let me
tell you something that place was the
dude I'll go back there
anytime that show at Riverside
that New Year show was the best New
Year's show I ever had the theater is
beautiful the nerve of people from San
Diego saying Riverside sucks is what's
the word insurmountable mean whatever
dude it means
in that situation their nerves dude
in Riverside it that was a great show
man it was an awesome show and those
that crowd was awesome there was one
piece of in the front I told him be
quiet and did he was quiet I'll go back
to that theater was awesome the was
it called what is it
Fox yeah and they were like they were
all like so tell people to come you know
we don't get many comedians and it was
awesome dude
and and wasn't gonna say oh this I got
this is crazy actually this guy
Ethan hit me up or no he didn't hit me
up all of his friends hit me up saying
that one of his that his girlfriend was
one of the people in that got killed in
in Las Vegas and the shooting and it
like it broke my heart man so I
looked at his Instagram and like he had
all these like pictures with her and her
name is Angela and she she was killed in
the Las Vegas thing man and they were
like they came to my shows before and it
was just it it me up because they
were like you know I met them and
and I you know I'd meet a lot of people
I don't remem didn't remember meeting
them but I I told Ethan I reached out to
him and I was like hey man I know you're
going through a rough time I know you've
been to some of my shows or whatever and
I just want to let you know some of your
friends reached out and I don't know if
this is appropriate but I wanted to let
you know that like I'll get you tickets
to not only my shows if you want to ever
come out but like you know you can also
also I I know a lot of comedians I can
get you tickets really to any comedians
if you feel like you know Matt now may
not be the time to laugh but if if you
ever feel like getting away and whatever
and and and and laughing for an hour I
can make it happen wherever and and he
wrote back a really sweet thing like all
thanks so much and you know this was
months ago and
Las Vegas shooting happen and then and
then I and then I and then and then he
hit me up and he was like hey we live in
Riverside I'm gonna buy tickets and I
was like dude don't buy tickets
I'll bring whoever you want oh I'll set
it up and I set it up and he brought the
family he brought it I thought he
brought his family to the show and I was
like I want to meet you guys after and
he said this is I brought her family and
it was just like really wild to meet
them and and it was I mean it's just
such an awful situation and you don't
you know it was just sweet that they
could they came and you know I know
obviously it was just they've been
through hell and I just like it was just
kind of an honor to have them there and
it it it I don't know I hope they could
at least forget a little bit about it
for a little bit and just laugh which
they said they laughed and that made me
uh that made me happy but man it's just
uh it's up I hope that there's
not not more of that kind of I
hope there's way less of that in
2018 but shout out to Ethan thanks for
bringing the family out
I met her her her dad which she made me
laugh and her an Angie's mom and Angie's
sister and all that and it was cool so
so rest in peace you know as they say
and yeah I don't mean to get so serious
this is a comedy podcast but I just that
that made me feel so anyway let's
lighten it up I this new year I don't
know if you have a new year's resolution
by the way like it's like oh I love
people who are like oh I'm gonna start
eating well in 2018 on like December
19th and they're like so let's go out
with a bang and they're just like eating
cake and stay
and like for like two weeks and they're
just like by the time New Year's
comes around they're like alright
today's the day
and they're like they eat one salad and
then they're light and then some oatmeal
and then they're like oh you and
then like a night delete like a
sandwich and they're like I'm doing it
kinda but it just feels like because
they were eating like for the past
holidays that now they're like eating
better but in real I ruin when reality
in in reality they were just eating a
little bit better they're eating better
than what they were in the past three
weeks or like when they're like hey I'm
not gonna smoke anymore and everyone
falls back on their new year's
resolution anyway my new year's
resolutions by the way was to start and
do stand-up 11 years ago oh wait
tomorrow January 2nd is my 11 year
anniversary for stand-up that was the
first time I got on stage and started
going every I was like I was like I'm
gonna do stand-up I'm gonna do it once a
week that's what my goal was
that was my resolution and then I went
on stage every second and then I went
back to every third fourth fifth six
seven that I went every day I think the
longest I haven't done stand-up in 11
years was like 10 days in a row I don't
think I've gone more than 10 days then
doing stand-up anyway yeah so if you
have a resolution
just that's yeah I mean I don't
want to say it's stupid now cuz now
you're did hear into it but like you're
gonna fail you know just like
come on dude
especially if you're a part of this cult
man if you have a resolution in you're a
part of this cult first of all alright
but second of all that was the worst
weakest first of all of them ever but
like second of all dude stick to it
cuz you're not coming to
the log cabin if you don't have
discipline I'll tell you that much man
dude this couple came up to me afterward
after my show and Riverside and they
were like so I hate this one that I do
meet and greets and they're like so
we're gonna do something kind of silly
and I was like you do whatever you want
I'm taking a picture and smiling you
know they'll do like can you
anytime we're gonna take this picture
you might can you and I go like yo yo yo
we're big
first of all we're big fans can you if
you're a big fan you already know the
answer to the question is no let's take
a picture like full-grown adults
you're a dolt or adult dude I'm not
can you do the stance you do
where you do know this couple came up to
me and they were like we're gonna do a
New Year's Eve celebration photo we're
just gonna do it like a kiss in front of
you and you can be in the background and
I was like all right and they both
leaned in like like bitch-ass
the dude did it like and
they kissed lips while I was behind them
and I was like smiling and then they're
like thanks and they're like let's see
the photo and they're like oh that
wasn't good it looks weird and I said I
could have told you that let's do a
regular ones like you wanna do a regular
one and they just felt weird and kind of
left but like yo just take a picture man
you're gonna be so disappointed you know
Oh what was that dude I just had to
you daily and try and come out of my
mouth madam um now um dude
like yeah can we just can we do you mind
if you can you flip the camera off no
cuz then I look like a douchebag
Who am I Tupac or Avril Lavigne
if anyone who flipped flicks off flips
up what'd he say flip or flick whatever
the camera it isn't Tupac is like look
you're not hardcore dude you're not
hardcore you're not you you would like
to think of like someone who's like this
at the camera just like and like they
work at Chase is hilarious you know like
go like this
can with this face yeah mmm it
I don't give a oh wait hold on I'm
late for work you give a you know
how you know you give a
cuz you got clothes on if you didn't
give a your dick would be all out
walking down the street just like no you
don't you care you care that's like it's
fine to say I don't give a but some
people are like yo I really don't give a
though I really don't give a
oh yeah your pants are on your pants are
on what's up with that you give a
your pants are on by the way this is the
motto for 2018 swear to God I
brought this up a few episodes ago about
when when you're making love and
and you leave your mouth open you don't
catch the drool dude 2008 the year
of the dog drool more that's the
motto 2018 drool more now I know I said
2008 and that's very stupid but that's
because I'm in it do you understand I'm
passionate and I'm in it which means I'd
drool more dude when you
are catching your spit and closing your
mouth so the drool won't come out you're
focused on the wrong man and you're
not living to your passionate potential
now I realize when I say that a lot of
dumb are gonna be like you
know what you're right I'm gonna be a
photographer go buy a camera and then
give it up in a month
but dude drew more drew more drew more
at your job in whatever your job
is if you work at Kaiser Permanente drew
more do this that you feel drill
more with your family if you have a
picnic and you're with your family and
you're loving it dude and you're hanging
out and your mouths open and that little
spits collecting and you're about to
and it's about to drool out of
your mouth but you close your mouth
you're taking yourself out of your
family moment to it let that drool slide
the down your chin
swear to god that's the most beautiful
when I see drooling I
know that they're into it dude fighters
drool cuz that's raw passion you
think they don't drool on each other
when they're in the Octagon I drool on
stage sometimes that comes out I'm
talking and I'm wet in the front
row because this is real life this
is Earth be on it don't catch your
own drool man that's some that's
some that's 2018 man drool more I swear
to God uh you know my goal is to reach
like 50 year olds that true that are
like you know what he's right and just
drool and just I do love my job and I do
catch myself catching my own drool
it
now do love working at Applebee's and
then just walk up can I take your order
and just drool comes out of
their mouths what would you like people
who don't miss the people would be like
uh I'm gonna go to Islands instead I
don't know if they have island they
don't have Islands everywhere but they
have islands of a restaurant
called islands in in like only Glendale
areas only Glendale Southern California
and it's so like we get it do it
it's one of those themed restaurants
works like you're on an island and
you're like we get it there's so many
plastic birds there and like
like spider plants and ferns and like
banana leaves and we're like can
we just eat you know and they have
Hawaiian shirts on like what dude we
would always go in high school do people
like let's go to Islands yeah let's go
to Islands and we ladies go to Islands
and everyone will always get the
chicken tacos a honk god dude and then
one time we were making a loud noise we
were talking and joking around in
islands and some guy was like can we
just eat can we just eat with our family
you guys are loud and we were like yo
this is Islands dude you're a restaurant
Islands his gun be loud you want a
nice dinner with your family
have it at home man he was mad he was
mad and I actually said to the
guy because he was so oh no I said to
him I was like that's not how you come
at someone first I always had this thing
where it's like if you're mad at someone
at first you got to be like hey excuse
me can you please maybe keep it down a
little bit cuz then you did it you're
nice if they don't then at least keep it
in mind
then you can be like yo
right but the first thing you said like
skeet you guys you know could you keep
it down and with my family and I was
like that's not how you're supposed to
do it first first you should have asked
nicely and since you didn't do that
that's a and then he said
something else really like rude and
and I was like if I stand up this is
gonna be funny that's what I said like
what a punk ass I was you know
alright dude
Square cash look everybody from my cult
is switching over to the cash up and
it's the number one finance app in the
App Store maybe it's because it's the
best way to pay people back maybe duh
friends families co-workers Cudas you
can pay them all back sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly in your bank accounts in
seconds Square cash is better than
everyone else all the other apps and all
that it's not a social network you don't
want to have their payments listed in
the feed I don't and this is the best
for that the new cash card is a black
debit card that you can design yourself
via the app the cash card allows you to
use the cash that you keep in the app
anywhere you want you get notifications
for all payments made to keep the card
made with the card directly via the cash
app laser at your card yaar tist ik
laser at your card draw your face on it
and it'll be delivered directly to you
for free draw a nice little
inspirational message if you
you're a follower of Christ draw across
the cash app team is constantly building
awesome new features so what are you
doing using the other guys get the cash
app today
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now blue apron is the number one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the conch for this next eight
weeks ending on two that's February 26th
blue apron is teaming with whole 30 to
bring you delicious recipes our menu
will a feature a not it's it's Italian
outer menu with a feature to hold 30
approved recipes recipes each week like
Mexican spice barramundi with avocado
togarashi chicken lettuce cups and I'll
let you know what country that's from
togarashi with avocado and kale and
sweet potato salad kick start a new year
with blue apron and a whole thirty blue
apron offers three plans the two-person
meal plan the family meal plan or the
wine plan which is six bottles of wine
from renowned wine makers delivered
monthly blue apron is treating
congratulations with Krista leah
listeners weird they type that all out
to their first three meals a $30 value
with your first order if you visit blue
apron calm slash Congrats so check out
this week's menu and get your $30 off
with free shipping at blue apron dot-com
/ Congrats blue apron a better way to
cook you know guys I don't get honest
with you on these ads too much but let's
get honest here you're supposed to brush
your teeth for two minutes twice away a
day but do you whether your answer is
yes or no or maybe which are all the
answers you need clip the electric
toothbrush that looks like it was
designed by Apple and cleans like
premium electric brushes but without the
high price it's really cool I bring it
on the road and I put it in my mouth and
it goes you know and it's getting all
the stuff that the regular toothbrushes
don't get clip is the new electronic
toothbrush that packs just the right
amount of vibrations into an ultra slim
design with guiding
pulses dude and I love pulses I don't
know if you like me bye love pulses and
it simplifies better brushing it's a
fraction of the cost of the bulkier
brushes dude it's real thin it makes you
feel you from the future with a movie
where it's like most of the guys are
white in it but then is like an Asian
guy in a black guy and it makes and
everyone's dressed the same in the
future and you could brush your teeth
it's like you know and some robot is
talking to you it's awesome the clip
electric toothbrush has been featured in
Forbes GQ Oprah's o List quip is backed
by a network of over 10,000 dental
professionals including desperate
dentists hygienists and dental students
coop starts with just $25 and right now
when you get when you go to get quit com
/ congrats to get your first refill
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill Peck
free and get quip calm / Congrats spell
GE tqu IP comm / Congrats drool more
2018 baby it's free conch you're allowed
to keep your drool in your mouth but do
you really want to come to the log cabin
leave that mouth open krokodil it up
crocodile it up beyond the edge of the
swamp baby beyond the edge of the swamp
hmmm am i angry that this microphone
doesn't stay still and i have to twist
it myself
wand fire yes does it make does it make
me angry a little bit am I gonna do
anything about it no one fire yeah my
gunfight my gun fire no one fire yeah
one fire every episode you know why cuz
one firefox op dude he's human you know
it's just what are we doing dude what
are we doing in 2018 we're gonna make
this world a better place do it i watch
this commercial I was in San
Diego or as I like to call it
piece of
Hill dude I was in San Diego or as I
like to call it cesspool town STD
central probably did if you're in it San
Diego and you don't have herpes you've
been there under a year god man imagine
living in San Diego dude I love the
tweets I'm gonna get there like it's
actually not that bad if you
yell
put your whole mouth on my taint
lift my balls up rest them on your nose
and go like this to my taint my
that's it for you and then be on your
merry way over to the Gaslamp
District anytime there's a district in a
City it sucks anyway you know
district dude you got some nerve
to call your area the district it's a
bunch of bars and people get date raped
you know district hey come on why is
there always a gas lamp district - what
the is a gas a gas lamp like this
like would they carry around what's
a gas lamp what the is a gas then
because it's got the pretty post with
the gas lamps on it that what look one
fire Google gas lamp district the first
image that came up was a police do not
cross yellow tape oh my god
here's another one it said it was at
Marquee and it said players welcome I
hope that means poker players and not
like right there other right players
welcome our players club that movie
my favorite when it was like
la give me love up in the club
debate give me love up in the club
Chicago give me love up in the club
Miami
give me love up from the club and then
he just keeps doing a bunch of cities
and then he fergan and he's like I don't
know what other cities and then by the
end he's like owner give me up in the
club owner of what of the club or is
that a city is owner a city gas lamp
district give me giving love up in the
cup don't date rape there give me love
up in the club people puking living
lover
we got a lupus up late in the club
there's a wildebeest in the paddywhack
get wagon up in the club her titties are
out give a love up in the club that's
illegal give them more love up in the
car the cops are right there letting it
happen love up in the car cuz they got
bigger problems give her love up in the
club oh my god dude the bay the bay dude
the yay
efore is the dude
the yay-yay area dude do you know the
song yeah area bro it's the most
[Music]
gay area song of all time
it's yeah area oh I love this
song
I love this song do it by e-40 remember
this song the diggable planet do
diggable planets worst game ever right
here alright
Oh coming so it's the fourth win I got
my second we appeal and then I got my
second wind short a second win of all
time then had another second win
you came I like how sometimes I like to
imagine I don't know why cuz to me in my
head efore t seeing us a little bit like
this and when you see us like this it's
a to me it sounds like Arnold
Schwarzenegger a little bit like he does
like it means anything like Arnold
Schwarzenegger is like yeah I could be a
rapper hell and he's just like I got my
second wheel to play off how many times
can afford to go in a song dude like he
I love you 40 like dude that guy I
love his music like almost like
Cana all of his songs
he's one those guys you could put on any
song and it's kind of the but dude
when he goes it's like he really wanna
push this wants to push that you thing
dude I mean how many times does he do
ooh in that song right up front
oh wait hold on the verse I forgot about
the versed in the beginning so many
sounds do it it loses his mind you want
to see the most losing ass mine clucking
in hip-hop this is my favorite
chick imagine he just loses his mind I'm
gonna play a little bit of the song and
then just imagine him his brain breaking
and then it's gone and he'll never be
the same right here watch I'll show you
right here after after the first verse
oh wait the pattern repeats in
background and the beat comes in
right here lost his mind
lost his mind dude must is mine put a
crib on hot coals you know Arnold
Schwarzenegger fill your batch about the
play akin to the ridin the lay
there keep right no little kind
of sounds like you're on a source dagger
to me I don't know that mean I think
that's just me look McCormick some
season the bloomer region oh my god dude
imagine efore T and Paul Simon hanging
out you know Paul Simon be like okay
okay here's my impression here's a
professional Paul Simon listening to e
40s music okay oh okay so okay so I
think I yeah so he just kind of huh
that's Paul Simon listening to you 40
like imagine like the guy whoever saying
who did made the sound I was like I
don't know what's that son you know the
rhythm we're talking about right but
first of all the worst song ever
all right toasted jam or whatever the
he says as what my baby feeds me
I'm her loving man literally has a
person in an insane asylum
she don't cook
mashed potatoes she don't cook t-bone
steaks don't feed me peanut butter she
knows that I can't take don't you know
don't make a song yet if that's what you
have to write about you know I
don't I never liked songs that they came
up with the rhythm first it's
like you have something to write about
first and then sing the song but
if you're like oh that's a funky rhythm
how about we just I like bread and
butter dude are you five iMac oh
my god and then in the fifth verse is no
more bread and butter no more toast in
gym make up your mind before you
make this song say yeah I like her says
genre pop get in the just talking
about bread and butter whoever wrote
that song is dead now but say yeah but
see yeah but see yeah every time I go
but see you my dog goes like does that
little pork head thing man
what Sam come here buddy hi video
podcast can check Sam out right now if
you're on YouTube although it's not up
until a day later usually two people
will hit me up and just be like when you
come out someone hit me up tomorrow and
be like hey when you come into San Diego
or what are you gonna be in Riverside
huge fan follow your every move when are
you gonna be in the place you were
yesterday
you know like unreal fan followed you
for literally followed you since glory
days this show that no one watched that
you were on followed your every move
seen everything you've ever done like
every Instagram picture when are you
going to be in the place that you just
left
you're three exits away from the place
you just let when you're gonna be there
um dude I put up an Instagram video of
me saying dude this is really gonna be
my year
how funny is it to think I couldn't get
I was thinking about dude how funny is
it to think that someone act like really
thinks like dude like I'm gonna make
this is actually gonna be my year I can
tell like I'm gonna I'm gonna
like hunker down and I'm gonna like get
my all organized and every year and
and and and this is gonna be my year and
then he and then ever and then pretty
much every day is the same after January
1st as it was in December and that
is so funny to me that attitude of like
let's do this but then like not
doing it but just having that attitude
but then not implementing the
things to make that this happen is so
funny to me like I used to I'm a
insane person dude I used to sit at
coffee shops in the at-at like you know
in the middle of the day and like
imagine people getting to coffee shop
would they when they would walk in the
coffee shops
I would imagine them waking up in the
morning at like 8:30 and thinking like
got up early feels so good
gonna be so productive and like
live today and kill today and
then they just kind of like got made
breakfast for themselves and then like
had a business call ish meeting but that
isn't gonna go anywhere and then was
like sat down again and like did some
writing on a project and then like
that's when they were like let me go get
a coffee I needed like a break and like
that's when I caught them and I would
imagine that for everybody that walked
in the coffee shop and just be
happy and just think how funny it was
that that was their day and then I would
also think sometimes like I like make up
stories about people that walk in like
one person like one of my favorite
was oh this guy gets so mad he blacks
out and like and then you like passes
out and falls down a little bit and then
wakes up and is like oh what
happen and like he got any and don't
worry doesn't remember the thing that he
got so mad at but his heart rate is so
accelerated and like his shirt is up a
little bit cuz he slid down the wall
[Laughter]
that is so fun and funny to me and
like and then people say like let's
go to a concert you man
you I just want to think of this
it makes me laugh dude today's the
day today's the day I get my
straight and you wake up at 8:30 or
maybe nine you know when other people
have woken up at like 7:00 and already
done and you just meet up with some
friends oh I love it dude I love it I
love it so much man it makes me
laugh dude I love laughing man better
than coming you ever see pumping iron
with Arnold Schwarzenegger when he's
doing the weightlifting and he's
like it's better than coming like you
know it's better than coming the pump
it's better than coming it's better than
coming Wow
how big was Arnold Schwarzenegger how
big must his ego have been when he was
the best at people still say he was the
best physique ever I don't understand
that by the way everyone they all look
the same to me they literally like some
guys he had their chest is a little
bigger their lats are too big or the
they don't have the Christmas
tree back I got whatever but like most
guys all look the same it's better than
coming but that
they judge and they're like that's the
guy that's the guy that wins and then
the guy in second place is like another
guy that looks the same and he PAH does
a pump and he's but it's better
than coming for him to I don't know man
but his his physique do those poses are
hilarious I think I talked about in my
first special those poses are so funny
some of those most of them are so
you know when they're just like showing
the tricep one the tricep ones my
favorite when they just showcase
the tricep one you can see on the video
pod but the oh man like what's
the end goal you know for that the guy
at the gym found a new workout that I
like to use to really get that burn the
you look the same what's it for
what's it for well I like to have a
strong core you got the core going
already
the the point here I hope that
one day I work out so hard I become I
burn I burn up and become a Phoenix
what's the goal you know the guy who has
the orgasms over and over again with a
guy who like has has that what's that
condition where you keep coming
you don't know what I'm talking about
there was a guy on the radio talking
about and it became it was like a little
bit viral Magoo my keep orgasming
condition one fire writes in keep
orgasming condition
you got it Wow persistent general
persistent genital arousal disorder what
if it was called keep orgasming
condition dude the guy keeps coming and
it sucks and he's like I hate having
orgasms and they'll just be talking and
it'll be like wait didn't we talk about
on the text chain yeah we did I thought
you were the one that showed us anyway
was like and he'll just be talking and
oh that's different
oh oh this guy who couldn't stop burping
ill ill
I thought that guy was the guy that
couldn't stop coming and we said it
sounded like he couldn't stop burping
okay okay
it was burping and I said it sounded
like it was kinda he was coming okay so
anyway he keeps coming dude and he was
like and it's really terrible sometimes
it's embarrassing you know he's like I
mean I got to go to funerals and
and like it's sad and I have to and I
have and sometimes the orgasms are so
intense that I have to like kneel down
and come at a Funeral I mean how can the
best life ever be also the worst life
ever you know damn dude I love how it
was like signs and symptoms and then it
was like a whole bunch of paragraphs
like just say coming physical arousal
caused by syndrome where this syndrome
can be very intense and persist for
extended periods days or weeks at a time
I mean the rameen Jesus with the
exception of known triggers is sudden
and unpredictable failure or refusal to
relit relieve the symptoms often results
in waves of spontaneous orgasms in women
and ejaculation in men I mean Jesus
Christ dude the symptoms can be
debilitating preventing concentration on
mundane - can you make it a little
bigger it makes it it seems like I can't
read I'm just trying to mundane I lost
my place one fire mundane tasks some
situations such as riding an automobile
or train vibrations from mobile phones
and even going to the toilet can
aggravate the syndrome unbearably
causing the discomfort to verge on pain
oh God
taking the arguably the best thing in
life in life
and making it the worst thing in life a
Dutch study has connected pGAD which was
is what it is with restless leg syndrome
due to an OBE I have restless leg
syndrome and that some that I
wouldn't believe in until I got I had I
do it a few years ago I started getting
it maddening it's maddening I can't you
can't sleep it wakes you up sometimes
physic there's like a little electric
current under your skin oh it's the
worst dude it's the worst it's probably
not the worst but it's bad yeah I get
that anyway oh okay so let's look
up these instagrams here we go let's
look up these instagrams Instagram I had
one that was all right that you
know
all right here's ready for the most
up Instagram post of the week
okay look here's what we're doing this
is the new year's edition of the most
up Instagram post of the week
somebody sent me this I think it's
probably a private account because they
they screenshot at it to me this is so
annoying dude I know it's just the the
what do you call it the inspirational
that I can't stand you know
promise me how do people write those
little letters on Instagram you know
they click copy and paste and they make
the little letters and that's I
don't its little enough that's the
little letters promise me isn't it and
then the period is not in little its
regular so it's a little too far away oh
and there should also shouldn't be a
period because it's the same sentence
that in 2018 you won't settle
not in a career that you hate not in a
town where you don't feel at home not
with friendships that aren't real and
especially can you guess it guys
babies can you guess it not with the
love promise me that this will be the
year will you take your life back from
what rock to you that you will remember
who you were before you let your faults
limit you and begin to let go of the
things that you held like sand between
your fingertips because you empowered
your insecurities instead of empowering
your confidence promise me that you'll
never run back to what shattered your
heart exhausted your mind and tempered
your soul promise me that you will no
longer give life to experiences that
haunt you like I love the
similes or whatever the metaphors like
ghosts and find what is what it is that
will grow within you like wild flower
and plant only that in the depths of
your scars oh Jesus Christ
your scars and most of all in caps
promise the me that when you gush about
love that you always mention yourself
first what cheers to a new year and a
whole world of possibilities my
beautiful angels imagine her going to
jail the next day after she wrote that
like oh well okay after this gosh only
about yourself first that's the
that is the meme this meme if I
ever heard it you know what I mean the
dude with the backwards camo hat on with
the red cup just like that's that meme
if I
ever heard it dude was that mean called
warm fire conceited oh he's a rapper
that's the conceited meme that's it
that is the conceded meme if I ever
heard um dude
the rapper named conceited you know but
yeah dude like come well come on dude
gush about yourself first that
even mean imagine talking to a person
dude I love my I love first of all I I
want to talk about my new boyfriend but
I love myself first I want to
tell you I'm amazed with myself
and I love myself now about my boyfriend
or about my girlfriend about my chick
about my new dude
anyway people got probs people got
prized let's go to Twitter huh I mean
this person already asked me about the
new year new me which is I already
talked about Chris D'Elia I saw this
from Laura Brown out Laura Lisa Marie I
saw a guy once whose truck was so jacked
up he literally needed a step stool to
get in thoughts oh come on dude
I don't believe that ice come a step
stool you know what I bet yeah that's
true even Google Image it I'm sure get a
car that you can get in you
get a car that you can get in
without using another apparatus Keith
Richards
at Keith's rich for 1-9 how crazy is it
that toupees are a thing you know i i'd
like to say yeah that's pretty insane
like if you get hair surgery that's one
thing because at least it's then it look
it's like you can't fall off but toupees
are pretty wild to me to put a fake
piece of hair on your head now that
being said i'm i have a pretty full head
of hair i mean i guess i have less than
i did ten years ago but i don't know how
it's light what it's like to be to be
bald yet or I don't know if I will but
um yeah it's who knows what that's like
that's the only thing a guy has to worry
about
dude one of my dog's mouth heads is
inside the other one's mouth why is he
like licking in a mouth that's what he
does all the time yeah I don't know what
that's like and but having a do pay
seems pretty weird but good the surgery
or wear hats or just be bald I think but
don't use that spray you know that
people do when they're starting to get
the ball like that's paint
hey that's paint you know it's
paint dude and you're painting your head
is wrong with everybody pretty wild
that we paint our heads it's and it's
infomercial guts got infomercial written
all over if there weren't infomercials
that wouldn't exist look how beautiful
it looks when you just apply you know
what I mean paint you you apply a little
bit to the top of the head Shh Oh his
head is painted
um anyway alright that's it I think I
think we're done
thanks for listening you guys it's a new
year so help me out with some more let's
build this cult mmm
cuz I'm not uh I'm not doing this if it
doesn't keep growing it's like a
business businesses have to grow or they
stop and I will stop mark my
words subscribe to the YouTube channel
watch it on YouTube download the Chris
D'Elia app for iOS or Android got the
app here I post on there different stuff
I post on Instagram and all that
it's more day-in-the-life daily life
subscribe rate and review the show
tweet me video episodes come up Tuesdays
or Wednesdays upcoming shows buy tickets
on crystally accom winnipeg calgary
saskatchewan pasadena tampa florida
upcoming shows Chris D'Elia calm watch
my specials watch my specials and oh I'm
on a new show called alone together and
I'm on a new show called alone together
it's on free form and they just released
the pilot
I think the just the first episode on on
the on the internet so you can google
that and I'm not on every episode I play
the main guys older brother so I'm in a
few with you I think two or three of the
episodes in anyway so thank you for
listening this episode is brought to you
by blue apron check out this week's menu
and get your $30 off with free shipping
at uefa.com / congrats and square cash
have you switched have you switched
download the free square cash after
designer cash card to get it for iOS or
Android now thanks my babies